all right it is wherever the president
United States to intervene in individual
commerce but the fact that he did and
ordered all meat plants to stay open
during what has been disrupted supply
had made about one-third of the nation's
beef of thatin largely the Midwest area
good chunk of it in Iowa has kind of
been frozen in place because of all
these problems with workers getting the
coronavirus at a number of facilities
not only there but in South Dakota and
other states as well I above governor
Kim Reynolds is with us right now
governor good to have you back how did
you feel with the president's order to
get these operations open yeah well
thank you you know it's great to be with
you again I appreciate the order that he
put in place and we're collectively
working with our processing plants we've
been in constant communication with over
40 of our manufacturers and processing
plants to make sure that we're working
with them to do you know additional
testing to make sure that they have the
PPE to make sure that where they're
doing putting all of the efforts in
place to make sure that they're
protecting their workforce at all as
well so that we can complete keep the
supply of food moving throughout the
country Iowa produces 10 percent of the
food supply and we're a fourth of the
processing in the state of Iowa and so
this is a critical and essential
workforce and a critical and essential
work production capability and so we're
working a tandem to make sure that we
can keep the food supply chain moving
and keeping America fed you know of that
workforce so many of them are very
nervous even Tyson Foods earlier on it
said that it was only going to keep
about 20% of its facilities open before
this presidential order a lot of those
workers feel that they're being forced
to go back under dangerous conditions
are they yeah so this is why I think the
testing has really been critical to this
and we have done a significant amount of
testing just in the last week working
with our facilities we've tested over
7500 the diagnostic testing of the
employees and then as well as we've done
the serology testing with over 5,000 and
we have scheduled 12,000
to both the diagnostic and the serology
testing over the next week and a half
and this really gives the employees I
think the confidence that they need to
feel safe in returning back to work with
the proper PPE as well as the conditions
in the facility and they're doing a lot
of that they're doing the testing as
they come in to check the temperature
they're making sure that they have the
PPE they're doing as much separation and
social social distancing as possible but
really I think our ability to get in
there and work with the facilities and
do the testing to really identify and
understand the scope of the virus and
the virus activity that's taking plane
place in the facility so we can identify
who's positive isolate them get them on
a road to recovery identify who's
testing negative and maybe separate the
two separate the the workforce in order
to really protect those that have not
tested positive so that's really been a
critical component I think of us
continuing to get the facilities up and
going and to keep them up and processing
as we move through this pandemic you are
opening slowly other parts of the stand
bleep restaurants first off I bye I'll
be at at 50% capacity I think salons
large gatherings amusement parks put off
until at least the middle of May is that
were things stand down yes it does so
we're opening up we've we've eased
restrictions and 77 of our counties and
we're seeing about 88 to 90 percent of
our positivity cases in the 22 counties
that will remain under the little higher
level of restrictions and that's phase
one so we've done we've opened up at 50%
capacity restaurants retail fitness
centers malls and then in Phase two we
hope to take a look at salons and
barbershops and continuing to open up
and bring more businesses back on you
know in Iowa we had over eighty percent
of our workforce that was essential work
that qualified under essential workforce
and so we had a relatively small amount
of businesses that were shut down but
still it's had a tremendous impact on
our small businesses and so we want to
make sure that we're opening them back
up but doing it in a safe and
responsible manner
Iowans are responsible they're
practicing personal responsibility as
well as our businesses and so we're
going to continue to look at the data
monitor the virus activity we're able to
do that by a statewide from a statewide
perspective to a county perspective
right down to a community and a zip code
so we can be targeted in our approach as
we begin to reopen Iowa and bring our
economy back online governor thank you
very very much